[Music]
[Music]
i'm the tour guide if you're looking for
the official tour guide this ain't it
this is the real real it's the real real
lee harvey oswald from there a below
average marine was able to pull that off
i don't think so nobody's buying that
what else you got jack ruby
the guy who shot lee harvey oswald why
would he do it the mafia ties they allow
him to mosey on into the police station
okay we'll believe that let's say you
believe that lana b johnson oh him and
jfk got along come on come on come on
how long are we gonna buy this guys it's
a real tour this is the real tour with
brandon shop i'm your tour guide we're
not buying this [ __ ]
[Music]
big boy
do it big you don't live twice you don't
get a chance to do it again let me show
you what the thick light feels like
thick light
thick nation
thick light
big
[Music]
you know we do it right never do it
light it's the thick light
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh the x's i'm glad you asked
uh the first one would be the shot which
to the autopsy was through the front the
throat so obviously didn't come from
that angle i was i think it came through
over here the grassy knoll with umbrella
man was that
then you have the magic bull theory
which that bullet traveled hit the
governor of texas right hit him in the i
think hip or leg
and then the final shot where everyone's
taking pictures smiling and [ __ ] which
is insane because the man died there uh
that was the shot through the the head
and that's where he died then they
gunned the car right gun line gun the
car drive through this right through
that uh all over there go straight to
the hospital to take jfk to the hospital
where the corner uh the bullet did go
through the front which makes no sense
if lee hobby oswald an average at best
marine sniper no did the shot
the car oh they they took the car wipey
clean bleach it of any evidence that
seems normal
and then the whole jack ruby like his
ties with the mafia he's clearly in the
mafia his ties in the mafia he knew lee
harvey oswald in new orleans there's a
whole new orleans connection and then
the dallas mafia which uh
jfk's brother obviously was trying to
shut down all that jfk was going hard on
the mafia which is weird because mafia
got jfk elected don't get me
on that
but uh
ruby ruby there's a speakeasy there's
like a gentleman's club where the dda
fbi agents the feds the mafia
johnson
ruby everybody would get together they'd
gamble they'd have drinks there'd be
girls there there's a whole club they
all knew each other so it's so strange
then jack ruby just moses into the
police station moses in nobody questions
them and he's allowed to shoot lee
harvey oswald and lee harvey oswald when
their question never admitted it not
once any sake he's always confused jack
ruby dies of cancer before he can say
anything but he kept saying he wanted to
talk to someone he kept going hey i have
a lot of information i need to talk so
we give you the truth then no one ever
interviewed they never let him say his
peace ever they died in prison come on
[Music]
oh you know just a normal regular friday
night shooting is special
that's it in dallas you know
tune in i got makeup on what's up
so this is the addison empire right yep
goddamn uber took me to the arlington
improv bro you know how hard it was
sending traffic coming from the wrong
comedy club
i want to just say who going up tonight
i'll feature
thanks for coming brother i'm happy they
got you the plus-sized green room
[Laughter]
keep it tight in here man yeah got to
say hi to some fans some people came and
took a photo with me
there you go
yeah
like a keyless celebrity out here
don't be killed man
come on now him and the makeup artist
got the same drink
[Laughter]
[ __ ] said let me get a sex on the beach
it's my new whiskey y'all it's called uh
nika
[Laughter]
the japanese one uh you know which one
the one with the man come on
are you putting your drink order yeah be
careful you get canceled can i get a
a nickel meat
please
should i get a knicker please
[Music]
[Music]
boy
[Music]
but it's good it was good
thanks brother
proud of you i appreciate you homie
yeah i am brother i appreciate you
calling man
we saw brendan
through his comedy show here in addison
improv so
was honored to see him absolutely
hilarious my first time seeing him do
his whole thing and uh dude it was it
was great man just what we need in this
serious time
gotta gotta get some laughs out and uh
brennan was absolutely hilarious we got
invited by brandon uh earlier today we
saw him at brunch and
uh the show was sold out but somehow he
made us he got some seats for us it was
amazing funny ass show
highly recommend just so good
it was murder season bro addison improv
bro yo
i mean i
i like kicked y'all's
door down like came in and rob dropped
and y'all can't do [ __ ] about it
four robbers came in your house justin
me chappelle and brendan
and we stole it all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on man you know i'm hungry dog
this is this ain't my sport as far as
favorite baseball players of mine i'm
gonna have to go with uh the famous
oakland a's athlete jose conseco he was
really a pioneer in the space of uh
abusing anabolic steroids as a
performance enhancing substance
oh hey
you know baseball is my life it's my
life passion of mine live my life one
ending at a time you know so i create
these thick boy jerseys
authentic hand sewn might be better than
your dodgers jerseys might be gonna have
to get them check them out high quality
go pass jerseys just get done with the
thick boy baseball shoe the two thickies
themselves big mark harley chappelle
you've never seen a more awkward black
guy around the sports field before ever
in your life
that's cool though man way out here
out here look at him
you know everybody does black friday
we're doing thick friday that's this
mother trucking friday we're doing thick
friday the jerseys you see we'll have
some dope built thick boy collab new
shirts and joggers you'll see those all
over the site thickboy.com
instagram it'll be all over you'll see
some it's thick friday dog there's black
friday there's thick friday we do a week
before the rest of the sheep do it black
friday [ __ ] black friday it's thick
friday